Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Elise LECAMP
J'aimerais commencer par vous
présenter quatre personnes,
deux hommes et deux femmes,
Florian, un jeune homme de 20 ans
qui n'a pas eu son bac,
mais qui adore bricoler avec son
ordinateur et qui adore les jeux vidéo.
À côté de lui, Emmanuelle,
une jeune femme de 44 ans,
qui a trois enfants,
qui a tenu une boulangerie pendant 12 ans.
Après, elle a eu
un accident cérébral grave,
et elle ne peut plus aujourd'hui
exercer son ancien métier.
Vous avez à côté Aizkoa,
une jeune femme qui vient du Pays Basque.
Elle était, il y a encore un an,
une institutrice dans une école
maternelle, et s'occupait des tout-petits.
Enfin Balthazar,
un jeune homme qui porte
un short l'hiver comme l'été.
Il a fait des études de cinéma,
et puis il s'est dit : « En fait,
je ne voulais pas faire du cinéma. »
Il s'est retrouvé au chômage.
Ces quatre personnes, si différentes,
qu'ont-elles en commun ?
Elles sont toutes, aujourd'hui,
devenues des développeurs.
Vous savez, un développeur,
c'est celui qui crée des sites internet,
des applications web et mobiles.
Ce métier, en fait, aujourd'hui,
est devenu tout à fait accessible.
Il s'est démocratisé considérablement.
On est loin de l'image du geek
boutonneux devant son écran.
Non, le métier s'est ouvert.
C'est d'ailleurs un véritable
accélérateur de carrière.
Quel autre domaine vous permet de changer
votre vie professionnelle
aussi radicalement ?
Dans ce domaine,
il y a de nouveaux métiers
qui apparaissent tous les jours.
D'autres meurent.
Par exemple, le métier
de webmaster a été remplacé,
il n'y a pas longtemps,
par le métier de community manager.
Vous ne le savez peut-être pas,
mais, en Europe, en 2020,
il va nous falloir 900 000
professionnels sachant coder.
Et 90 % des métiers exigeront
des compétences numériques.
Dans ces conditions,
travailler dans le numérique,
c'est passionnant.
Il y a le métier de développeur,
d'autres métiers en pénurie,
comme UX designer,
community manager, data scientist.
Travailler dans le numérique,
c'est passionnant,
mais peut s'apparenter
parfois à un marathon,
parce qu'il faut courir
de plus en plus vite,
rester à jour.
Il y a aujourd'hui
des développeurs au chômage,
comme il y a aussi
une pénurie de développeurs.
Et les développeurs au chômage,
ce sont ceux qui n'ont pas couru
assez vite, qui ont décroché.
Alors, dans cet univers
où tout va de plus en plus vite,
suite aux nouvelles
technologies qui évoluent,
est-ce que cela fait encore du sens
de faire des études longues ?
Sert-il encore à quelque chose
de faire un master, un bac+5 ?
Pensez-y.
Ce que vous allez apprendre
en première année
va devenir obsolète en cinquième.
Et ce que vous allez faire trois ans
après la fin de vos études,
n'aura probablement plus rien
à voir avec ce que vous avez étudié.
Non, cela n'a plus de sens
de rester, pendant des années,
éloigné de la vraie vie professionnelle.
Alors,
pourquoi entend-on, aujourd'hui,
certains dire que
les études se prolongent,
qu'il y a des étudiants qui veulent faire
des études plus en plus longues,
qu'on se contente de moins en moins
d'un bac+2, bac+3 ?
On veut faire un master,
et puis il y en a qui veulent
faire un doctorat.
Il y a une véritable inflation
des diplômes.
Vous allez me dire que ce sont des métiers
qui demandent
de plus en plus de compétences.
Eh bien non, ce sont les formations,
désolée,
qui sont de moins en moins adaptées.
Et après une formation
de trois ans, inadaptée,
l'étudiant ne se sent pas prêt
pour affronter
le vrai monde professionnel.
Donc il va faire encore
des années d'études.
Et après un master, un bac+5,
il ne se sent toujours pas prêt,
pas plus qu'après un bac+3.
Et demandez à un thésard
s'il se sent prêt.
Non, on n'est jamais prêt.
Figurez-vous qu'un ami à moi
a dû supprimer de son CV
la mention de son doctorat
pour enfin être embauché.
En fait, notre système scolaire nous
pousse vers de plus en plus d'études,
vers la carrière universitaire
dans un sens.
Or à l'université,
il n'y a pas de débouchés.
Alors, comment apprendre autrement ?
Comment changer le système ?
Comment le rendre
plus efficace, plus agile ?
plus proche des besoins des métiers ?
Comment, enfin, éviter ce coût
extraordinaire pour la société
des années d'études
pour apprendre des métiers
sans débouchés ?
J'ai envie de partager
avec vous trois idées.
Première idée :
il faut arrêter de penser
« études longues » .
Il faut penser court, modulaire.
Je fais une formation de cinq mois
et puis je vais travailler.
Et puis plus tard, je vais faire
une autre formation de cinq mois,
et puis je vais travailler.
Deuxième idée :
il faut arrêter de
cloisonner l'enseignement.
Il faut arrêter de distinguer
« formation initiale »
et « formation continue ».
Pensons ensemble.
Pierre, un jeune homme,
vient d'avoir son bac.
Il va s'inscrire à l'université.
Il va peut-être aller
dans une école d'ingénieurs.
Il va faire ensuite cinq ans d'études
pour ensuite travailler
comme développeur logiciel.
Et puis prenons Marc,
un jeune homme de 30 ans,
technicien du secteur automobile,
qui va faire une formation d'un an,
et ensuite, il va travailler
comme développeur logiciel.
Est-ce justifié
que l'un va faire des études de cinq ans
pour apprendre le métier que l'autre
va apprendre en une année ?
Ma troisième idée, le numérique.
Il nous permet d'automatiser
une partie de l'enseignement.
Imaginons...
Vous êtes en train d'écouter un cours
sur comment parler en public,
votre enseignant va vous
parler de bonnes pratiques,
va vous partager ses techniques.
Et en fait cet enseignant
va répéter les mêmes techniques
plusieurs fois, devant plusieurs salles,
autant de fois qu'il va donner ce cours.
Avec l'outil numérique,
l'enseignant va pouvoir enregistrer
son cours en vidéo,
va écrire dans un document
en ligne la consigne,
et ensuite, il va rendre
disponible ces ressources
à tous ses étudiants
avant même le début du cours.
Ainsi les étudiants,
quand ils arrivent en cours,
ils sont préparés,
ils peuvent poser des questions,
et l'enseignant peut aller plus vite.
Donc, l'outil informatique
permet de gagner du temps,
et avec ce temps,
l'enseignant peut se consacrer davantage
à l'accompagnement individuel
de chacun de ses élèves.
À partir de ces idées,
j'ai créé la Wild Code School,
une école où on forme
des personnes issues d'horizons divers
au métier de développeur web en cinq mois.
Dans cette école, nous
ne faisons pas de distinction
entre la formation initiale
et la formation continue.
On utilise aussi l'outil numérique
pour automatiser une partie
de l'apprentissage,
et pour faire gagner du temps au formateur
pour qu'il puisse davantage se consacrer
à l'accompagnement
individuel de ses élèves.
À ce propos, j'aimerais
vous raconter une histoire.
Il y a dix ans, j'étais jeune
enseignante à l'université.
J'avais 25 ans.
J'animais un cours
avec un professeur expérimenté.
J'avais envie d'améliorer
mon enseignement,
d'aller au-delà des exposés classiques.
Donc, j'ai imaginé des exercices
ludiques, des ateliers interactifs,
des jeux sérieux.
J'ai proposé cette nouvelle
méthode à mon professeur.
Malheureusement, il n'a pas
du tout apprécié.
Il m'a dit :
« Anna, cela ne fait pas partie
de notre tradition universitaire.
Cela ne va pas marcher,
et de toute façon,
les étudiants vont faire la grève. »
Qu'est-ce que j'avais à faire ?
Soit j'essaie, je poursuis avec mes idées,
et je risque la sanction,
je ne pourrais plus compter
sur le soutien du professeur,
ou alors, j'abandonne,
je fais comme tout le monde,
je m'inscris dans
la « tradition universitaire ».
Bon, je me suis déjà trop investie
dans la préparation
de mes exercices interactifs
pour laisser tomber comme ça.
Donc, j'ai décidé de poursuivre.
Donc, je fais ma méthode, mes exercices,
le professeur n'a même pas
remarqué, d'ailleurs.
Et finalement les étudiants ont apprécié.
Ils ont réussi leurs examens,
et personne n'a fait grève.
Cette histoire m'a fait
comprendre une chose :
si on en croit en quelque
chose, véritablement,
quelles que soient les difficultés,
il faut essayer, expérimenter,
il faut oser.
Ça va peut-être échouer,
mais ça peut aussi réussir,
et là, vous aurez gagné.
Donc moi, j'ai osé créer
la Wild Code School.
Et c'est parce que j'ai osé,
qu'Emmanuelle, Aizkoa, Florian, Balthazar,
et des dizaines d'autres
ont, aujourd'hui,
un métier où ils s'éclatent.
Merci à vous.
(Applaudissements)